19th century philosophy or sometimes as
it's called late modern philosophy is an
area that has been at least in recent
years not paid as much attention to as
it probably deserves it's an area that I
am particularly interested in in which I
do a good bit of my scholarly work and
devote a lot of my reading and attention
to and I was asked a question a few
weeks ago by one of my viewers about
which figures which would be the top
figures that I would recommend if
somebody was going to study 19th century
philosophies so I thought haha good I'll
do another top ten west and as I started
drawing it up I found that it was very
difficult to to carry out the kind of
triage that was being demanded I was
scratching some you know thinkers out
very reluctantly and trying to insert
other thinkers and saying well you know
we need some sort of representation of
this this group here this school how our
people are going to get a good spectrum
and long and short of it is if you're
going to confine yourself to ten
thinkers you're not going to get an
adequate representation of the full
spectrum of what's going on in 19th
century thought and unfortunately that's
what often happens in classes where
we're 19th century philosophy it's
taught if it's taught as a standalone
course it'll often just be German
idealism plus existentialism plus John
Stuart Mill or maybe if the instructor
is particularly interested in pragmatism
plus William James or you know and we
could do this with a lot of other things
and it's unfortunate because there's
there's such rich thought there that
deserves being made part of one's
philosophical development and I think
that you know in the current
philosophical milieu there's so many
people that you can study that by the
time that we get to the 19th century
people are often worn out
we're looking at it the other way around
there's so many you might say not
necessarily hasty but need to be called
back in question judgments that were
made from the vantage point in the 20th
century about the quality or or value of
19th century thought that one you know
if one is really a philosopher one
actually want to read the text oneself
so then make a judgment based on that
rather than listening to Bertrand
Russell or you know any really any of
the people that who are sort of saying
well that that stuff that's been done we
don't need to think about it anymore
because there's a lot of really
brilliant stuff going on even in the
thinkers that we think that we know
really well like Nietzsche or Hegel or
John Stuart Mill once you probe beneath
the surface or you actually attentively
read the text you find out there's a lot
more going on then you you might at
first have thought so what I want to do
here instead of giving a top ten list is
to I will highlight some philosophers in
particular and actually I'm sticking
fairly close to an article or an
encyclopedia entry that I wrote some
time ago which I'll put the link in my
video description so you can access it
and print it out if you want to about a
19th century philosophy I was confined
to a limited word count so there's other
people that I would have put in and I
would have said more about them but you
know you got to work within the limits
that your your assigned so what I want
to do is talk less in terms of
particular figures as the centerpieces
and more in terms of philosophical
movements or schools or particular
problems and thematic that they were
they were working on some of these
resist classification a bit more than
others it's hard to figure out exactly
where to fit certain figures sometimes
but I think that
you can identify about 11 or 12 main
movements or groupings that you can put
19th century philosophers most 19th
century philosophers into and those are
in the order of my you know treating
them and and perhaps in order of
influence if not importance British
empiricism / utilitarianism because
those often went hand in hand that would
be one major one German idealism another
really significant movement with a lot
of interesting thinkers in it what I'd
like to call German pose to galleon
philosophy rather than just calling it
you know late idealism or German
materialism or things like that and
existential philosophy there's gonna be
a little bit of overlap there american
transcendentalism positivism of both the
you know British and the French and also
a little bit of the German kinds
pragmatism primarily an American
movements a rubric that I'm going to
call social philosophy under which quite
a few distinct thinkers fit who are all
treating a set of common issues and
themes
something that a lot of people aren't
really attuned to French reflexive
philosophy another another school of
philosophy that was primarily French
authors traditionalism another is on two
loge ISM and then we have neo Thomism
and British idealism and those are all
interesting well represented
philosophical schools that you could you
could you know write a whole
dissertation on you could spend years
researching each one could could have
its own Encyclopedia article because you
could read quite a bit about it so let's
talk about you
one intern British utilitarianism and
empiricism if I and I'll try to be very
brief to keep the list very short if you
were only gonna pick two people to focus
on with this although he's sort of
straddling the 19th and 18th century I
would say that Bentham is in many
respects a 19th century thinker and so
you know he even though some of his
works his major works have written in
the 18th century they're carrying
through into the 19th century so I would
read Bentham of course John Stuart Mill
is he's worth reading in part because
when it comes to utilitarianism not only
is he making important modifications to
the theory he's also somebody who grew
up within it's its worldview he was a
project they were there he was a child
who experienced utilitarianism as a
living philosophy German idealism
there's there's a lot of figures who we
could mention if we could only read to
which one which one is would those be I
would say Hegel and Schopenhauer it's
it's nice to read Fichte it's nice to
read shelling there's a lot of other
interesting thinkers like ya Kobe who
are worth spending some time on if
you've got the time but if you only have
the time to read to post Conchi and
philosophers who are really not just
personally in show Carver's case but but
philosophically opposed to each other I
would say Hegel and and Schopenhauer
once we get past Hegel and we're into
you know what we could call post a
galleon you know right hey galleon left
to galleon philosophy obviously the most
important person to read when it comes
to that would be Marx
but I think it could be if you could
only pick one other person to read of
that group I would say looking for BOTS
who is in some respects a predecessor of
Marx but Marx isn't picking up on
everything that feuerbach is doing
they're both materialists they're both
humanists but they both have interesting
ideas going on existential philosophy
you know the two main thinkers for the
19th century and this is sort of you
know reading things back would be of
course Kierkegaard and Nietzsche but the
connections between them are not really
recognized by most people until the 20th
century but it's nice that we actually
have that convenient thing to put you
into because where do they fit in
schools it's very it's very difficult to
say is Kierkegaard a German idealist
well he's not German and he's he's he's
using the language of German idealism
doing some very different things with
that is Nietzsche you know in in post a
galleon philosophy what are these doing
something really unique of his own so
there's there's that now moving across
the ocean and looking at transcendental
philosophy I think it could be useful
actually to read Coleridge who's the guy
that he's British thinker and he's the
guy that the transcendentalists are
getting a lot of their German idealism
through along with Victor Cruz an but I
would say that it's most important just
to read these guys and I would say
Emerson and Thoreau are the two thinkers
that you would want to look at most
closely there's there's other thinkers
as well as you know in any movement but
and we want to keep it simple Emerson
and Thoreau pragmatism pragmatism is is
getting started and as an American
philosophy in the nineteenth century
with Charles purse and he originally
calls his philosophy pregnant
and then James comes along William James
and says ah this is exactly what I had
in mind and he does something quite
different from it different enough that
purse will say you've stolen my my name
from me
I'm gonna call my philosophy prank
mattes ISM because nobody that's such an
ugly word nobody will steal it and and
person James really do complement each
other quite well I think it would be
tempting to put in ruse there but if we
want to keep it simple and say two
thinkers Charles person and William
James going to this this this sort of
broad category of social philosophy then
there's a lot of thinkers and I'm not
just gonna confine myself to two that
would be worth looking at one of them
already fits into British utilitarianism
and that's John Stuart Mill mill is
interested in these these issues as well
and he's engaging some of these thinkers
another person who's sort of doing the
same doing similar things in many
respects to mill but not from a
utilitarian perspective would be Alexis
de Tocqueville who not only wrote you
know democracy in America but also a
interesting analysis about why the
revolution occurred the French
Revolution and investigated prison
conditions the United States there's
there's a lot there but I would say that
there's there's three other thinkers
well four other thinkers that you would
want to look at as well
one is Charles Fourier he advocates this
this interesting phalanx system he's
trying to rethink society from the
ground up and create a more rational
society
I read assess Simone as well comes up
with some some interesting ideas much
sterner somebody who you could fit into
the sort of posted galleon area is is
also somebody who fits in here
not on the side of society per se but
rather on the side of the individual and
another person who I think would fit in
with that quite well would be me
Mikhail Bakunin also you know he's
really he wants a different kinds of
kind of society but he he is in effect
an anarchist and and and that means he's
going to be standing up for the the free
individual against rule so a lot of
people with that we can also talk about
French reflexive philosophy and I'm
actually gonna throw somebody else in
here who doesn't completely fit into it
but we want to talk about French
philosophy to some degree so around the
turn of the century there's this guy who
is practically unknown to anybody who's
not French
and that's man to be ran and man to be
ran has some really interesting analyses
of the mind of volition in in in some
respects he's a way to bypass Conte and
there's this entire tradition it in
French philosophy that people outside of
it often don't know what to make of but
it's it's it's quite identifiable as as
French reflexive philosophy on the way
to that would be somebody who's an
eclectic thinker deliberately like
Victor Cruz an but at the very end of it
we would have I guess you could put both
of these thinkers into this this light
we're gonna Maurice blown-down who's
publishing towards the end of the
century and almost at the same time on
ray birdsong and both of them are doing
somewhat similar things they're they're
often likened to be doing phenomenology
but they're actually coming out of this
this reflexive philosophy tradition and
they revitalized metaphysics in France
for the twenty
century they were extremely fertile
figures they also prepared the way for
the reception of phenomenology in in
France in the 20th century
traditionalism traditionalism is another
one of these 19th century's
philosophical movements that a lot of
people don't know much about and it's
interesting because it ended up having
an important political effect in France
through the the organization axial
process and their philosopher Sean
Burroughs and then through that it
influenced a lot of other regimes that
we often categorize as fascist or you
know dictatorships but we're actually
integral nationalist regimes and so some
of these ideas play come to play an
important role the traditionalist would
include people like Joseph to my stand
félicité la Monnaie and luiz de bois now
all three people you know very obscure
these days in the sense that barely
anybody's heard of them but they were
actually doing some pretty interesting
work back then onto lo jism is is
another philosophical movement that sort
of arises within the matrix of Catholic
thought the way the way traditionalism
originally did it was actually
traditionalism and onto lodges and were
actually both condemned the guy who
often gets associated with that would be
Rosa Meany although he is he's got a
contemporary vincenzo Joe Bertie who is
who's also non too low just and they
they end up influencing the American
philosopher arrestees Bronson but also
we got neo tome ISM the 19th century the
the second half that sees a revival in
Catholic circles of what was not ever an
official Catholic philosophy but often
for many people
took on that and that would be the you
know philosophy of st. Thomas and what
had happened up until this time was that
much of the thought of Thomas Aquinas
when people were actually using and it
was mostly Dominicans and a few Jesuits
that are interested in it they would
deal with it in a very schematic way and
they were you know they were they're
interested in having these manuals they
weren't interested in you know sort of
approaching Thomas's thought in its own
right and hopefully will the 13th who's
really well known for the railroad
annavaram the social philosophy stuff
also had an encyclical in which he said
look we need to spend time paying
attention to Thomas Thomas actually is
one of the smartest of these doctors we
need to you know take into account what
he has to say never said that he's the
official philosopher because the church
doesn't have this such but it certainly
elevated its status and so this gets a
whole movement going that is gonna go
full bore into the 20th century finally
we have another you know movement that
again like traditionalism not a lot of
people pay attention to I think in this
part because they think that the
analytics you know gave the death knell
to this and therefore it's it's not
worth studying but that would be British
idealism Britain you can call it British
a galleon ISM if you want but it's
really you know
idealism and Bradley would be an
important figure in this so would Thomas
green and they're well worth worth
studying I think the last thing that I
want to say about 19th century
philosophy I've given you a lot of names
I've given you a lot of movements I want
to talk a bit about some of the main
uniting themes that are being dealt with
in in 19th century philosophy not not
exclusively it's not as if 20th century
or you know early modern philosophy or
ancient philosophy didn't didn't tackle
any of these but they have a particular
emphasis that leads to a kind of milieu
that you can you can describe one of
them is making sense out of the the
effects of the Enlightenment which is
you know very recent in time and is
still carrying through into the 19th
century and making sense out of in
particular the French Revolution but
also to a certain extent the American
Revolution but the French Revolution you
know especially because it led to what
was almost the form you know what you
could call it a precursor to a world war
you know the Napoleonic Wars which
lasted over ten years involved every
single country in Europe at one time or
another and had incredible repercussions
well outside of the European sphere in
Africa in Asia and in America not only
you know militarily but politically
economically intellectually people ended
up having to sort of take sides and
there was a lot of you know debate and
discussion about what is the meaning of
the Revolution was it first was it a
good thing or was it a bad thing to you
know is it is it a aberration or is this
the way that everything else is going so
the revolution provided a real linchpin
a litmus sester for people's thinking
the analysis of the knowing the
conscious the active the working subject
that were being you know given a lot of
attention in early modern philosophy all
the way up to Kant those continued
through
to the 19th century and you really
couldn't avoid doing some philosophical
anthropology and some epistemology if
you were a 19th century philosopher you
had to explain where do ideas come from
how do we work with them how do we
affect things out there in the world the
problem of other minds begins to you
know really assert itself as a key issue
how we can understand each other all of
those sorts of things and the 19th
century is much more attuned to the fact
that we are linguistic that we are
historical that we are cultural that we
are interrelated beings than the the 9th
in the 18th century and and you know the
early modern period was that's why you
have so much emphasis on you know
language culture history all these these
great themes along with that this is the
third theme we can identify is the
attitudes towards the past it's not just
making sense out of this French
Revolution business and you know the war
is and the terror and you know the
elevation of the peasant and all these
these these other themes it's it's also
thinking about the whole past of
philosophy so you have people like Hegel
for example saying well you know all
these other thinkers we can we can see
them as leading up to some sort of point
or your narrative might be you know rise
and then fall or perhaps even just fall
from the beginning all right but there
is some sort of narrative there about
the the past and there's also a
narrative about the present and the
future some of these thinkers believe
that progress is inevitable we still
have to give it a little push here and
there we have to join in others think
that degeneration is unstoppable as well
and we have to find ways to you know
secure ourselves a refuge against the
degeneration of modern culture and
modernity and democracy and socialism
and you know the utilitarian approach to
things and modern industry it sounds
like Nietzsche right but but there's
other thinkers in that vein as well I
would say if we want to come you know
emphasis on the past and emphasis on the
future is two different themes we have a
15 in this this intense focus on social
structure on institutions and in
particular on class conflict and how
class conflict ought to be understood
and how it ought to be addressed so
that's that's a particularly interesting
and important theme finally I would say
that another key theme that that comes
up and this is one of those for and
against type of things as well is is
religion what what we make of humanity's
religious impulse of our religious
institutions Europeans and Americans at
this time are becoming much more exposed
and they were in previous centuries to
other religious great religious systems
and ways of thinking about things and
they have to figure out how can we how
can we reconcile all of this some
thinkers you know like Marx you know
religion is the is the opiate of the
masses it puts them sleep but it helps
them deal with their pain but it's
really just a drug that they become
addicted to Hegel saw religion by
contrast as just one step short of
philosophy not all the religions they
were like enough you know progress up to
that point
Schopenhauer thought that that some of
the the eastern primarily Indian
religions could could tell us much about
the nature of reality that that Western
philosophy from a Content perspective
would also corroborate and we could go
on from there you know the
traditionalists actually
that that religion was one of the things
that the Revolution had tried to sweep
away but really tried to just replace
itself with and calmed who I should have
mentioned under positivism I'm not sure
if I actually got to positivism or not I
may have skipped over it wanted to
replace the the Catholic Church with a
religion of humanity so we see that that
religion and religious viewpoints
institutions beliefs the past the future
the nature of the divine these are all
wrapped up into one one big theme that
plays another major role so I would say
you know if you there's other things as
well that these guys are talking about
but if you if you look at these these
themes those are the things that are
really motivating many of the thinkers
there's other things that we could talk
about as well you know women's suffrage
and and liberation and feminist
critiques that's important there's you
know because of slavery and it's it's
it's repercussions all the way
throughout the 19th century there's you
know important important critical
movements within African American
philosophy there's other things that we
could we could talk about as well and
perhaps some I'm not giving them as much
emphasis as I want to but this is
already a lot so to answer that that
viewers question you want to study the
19th century philosophy these are the
sorts of things I think that you want to
focus on and pay attention to again I've
got that encyclopedia entry which is
just you know scratching the surface but
can actually get you started link to in
the description for this video so that
might be a decent place to to begin